I'm here at South by Southwest with Gary
Vaynerchuk Gary great panel just now one
of the things that came up was just the
sheer velocity that the technology seems
to want us to move at right and we're
seeing a lot with maker spaces of groups
of individuals kind of coming together
and doing amazing projects and the
question I have for you is like what
role do you see for larger companies
kind of participating in this in the
future and what what's going to separate
out the winners from the losers in the
big companies in in this kind of
accelerating game of catch-up
that's a big question right you know
it's a it's a it's a leading question
right I mean the truth is this all the
cliche terms that we all like to be
cynical about authenticity transparency
speed they actually matter like the
reason they became cliches is the reason
stereotypes become stereotypes there's
micro truths in them right and so I
think the brands that are and the
businesses are gonna win are the ones
that understand context let me explain
for you to win you have to understand
the context of the room you're playing
in right like I can't walk into a room
of people that really understand social
media and give 101 of like here you need
to put your app on your phone and then
you've got a tweet and here's ID because
we're gonna check out and they're not
gonna care right and so for me and so
for me what's really the problem is that
brands and businesses are not con
texting the universe right now they
don't realize how fast it is they don't
realize how quick change is happening
they don't realize that the customers
[ __ ] radar is better than ever
before they don't realize that they have
to make great content on a daily basis
everywhere all the social networks blogs
everywhere every banner at every email
you have to be great you have to bring
value you know why because we have a
supply and demand issue
everybody's talking which means there's
a lot more people that people have to
listen to which by default means you're
not gonna listen to anybody which makes
it much harder to actually get consumed
so I believe that the businesses and the
brands of the world right now are
disrespecting how tough it is out there
they think they can just get by they
can't and that's why they're gonna lose
right and you know I just a pile on
there right but one of the things that
kind of struck me recently is they were
always too slow but in the past they had
the advantage of access to capital but
then you talk to guys in these maker
spaces now and people are telling us we
talked to a guy today and he said look
you can build a company now for less
than it used to cost to do a focus group
so that the speed advantage is gone and
now the capital advantage
is gone because you can do amazing
things with rapid prototyping with
sensors right that doesn't require more
than a few thousand bucks just to get
started yes I mean I'm completely
confused at people's lack of
understanding that the scale advantages
the scale of distribution and the money
continues to the Internet has squeezed
the end-user to the product that's it
everybody in the middle is vulnerable
right right right period and the cost of
doing thing do you know what this cost
this interview ten years ago with a big
[ __ ] camera I don't know if you bleep
that on your website you know big camera
and a goddamn satellite dish to be it
was expensive the world is moving so
quickly that cost is not there anymore I
mean I'm just completely baffled by
people's lack of understanding of what's
really going on and what is going on is
the Second Industrial Revolution we are
living through the biggest culture shift
of our time since then and people are
not adapting to that reality right well
some of them are but a lot of them are
doing in loose collaborative networks ad
hoc project based organizations right
it's perhaps feared the institutions the
institutions are struggling to it bits
are in trouble right right right don't
what listen when you don't have money
you go and get money you know when you
have lots of money you go and try to
save the world because they're driven by
different things they don't even see it
they don't even see it they don't see it
do any of them see it is there Neela you
know what's so funny
yeah the ironic part is I actually think
all of them see it I really do but
they're crippled by making numbers each
quarter for Wall Street or if I can hold
on to the numbers of sales for the next
two years my bonus as CEO of this big
company is going to be ten times bigger
so why would I take money from the PL
and invest it which personally affects
me differently now we're getting into
the real conversation which is that
human beings make decisions that are in
their best interests not necessarily the
logo of the company they work for
right that's so you know I actually
think many of them actually I say they
don't see it because I'm judging them by
their actions I actually think they do
see it
but I could only judge my ones actions
right on man thanks a lot yeah thanks
great token Thanks yeah